in the Greek New Testament there are two
words that the King James version will
typically translate as hell one final
point about the pit and we
begin remember I said is hell in the Old
Testament we've proven that right but
let me just make one final point about
the pit that relates to our Lord Jesus
Christ I will cite Zechariah Chapter 9:
9-1 which is an important text because
it's applied to Jesus Christ in the New
Testament Zechariah 9: 9-1 this is
applied to the Lord Jesus Christ in the
New Testament which again confirms that
Jesus is saving you from the pit of Hell
not just the grave this why I want to
connect it with the New
Testament according to the New Testament
application of this text Jesus comes to
save you from the pit of Hell by his
blood that he shed to ratify the
Covenant between us and him right that's
one of the stipulations and blessings of
the Covenant if we enter into Covenant
relationships with our God then one of
the blessings promised by our God to us
who enter into Covenant relationship and
accept the New Covenant between God and
us is that he will save and redeem you
from the pit Rejoice greatly oh Daughter
of Zion shout oh daughter of Jerusalem
Behold thy King cometh unto thee notice
this is going to be fulfilled in our
Lord he is just and having salvation
lowly and riding upon an ass upon a cult
the fo of an
ass and I will cut off The Chariot from
Ephraim and the horse from Jerusalem and
the battle bow shall be cut off and he
shall speak peace unto the Heathen and
his Dominion shall be from sea even to
the Sea and from the riv R even to the
ends of the Earth as for thee also now
watch the promise to every individual
believer every individual member of the
body of the Lord Jesus Christ every
individual member of the New Covenant
right as for thee the word thee means
you One Singular thee thou thine thy
means one by the blood of thy Covenant
by the blood of thy Covenant the
Covenant I made between you and I I have
sent forth thy prisoners out of the pit
wherein is no water the promise is
Jerusalem's King will
come and he'll be riding the full of a
donkey to bring Salvation to his people
and judgment to his enemies and by the
blood of his Covenant the blood that he
sheds to ratify the Covenant all who
accept the Covenant will be set free
from the waterless pit this again proves
that the pit is not the the grave
because even as Believers we die
physically until the Lord returns it
must refer to Hell and Hell Is waterless
because there's no water in hell but
fire whether the fire is literal or
metaphorical we'll get to that let me
show you the Lord fulfilling it I'm G
show I'm use the Revis Standard Version
John 12:
12-6 here you go so you can prove that
the New Testament interprets these
passages the New Testament interprets
these
passages as being references to hell or
Hades so the New Testament inspired by
The Same Spirit that inspired the Old
Testament is explaining that the pit
Hades Hades does refer to the afterlife
and does refer to punishment of the
wicked not everyone in Hades was being
punished but you get the point
right and here it is John 12 12-6 so
don't let anyone deceive you and tell
you otherwise there is no better
commentary on the Old Testament than the
New Testament if you're a Christian the
next day a great crowd who had come to
the feast heard that Jesus was coming to
Jerusalem so they took branches of palm
trees and went out to meet him crying
hosana blessed is
he who comes in the name of the Lord
even the king of Israel and Jesus found
a young ass and sat upon on it as it is
written fear not Daughter of Zion behold
your king is coming sitting on an a as's
cult so did Jesus fulfill Zechariah 9911
yeah his disciples did not understand
this at first but when Jesus was
glorified then they remembered that this
had been written of him and he had been
done to him but now the blood of the
Covenant his blood of the Covenant that
sets the prisoners fear here you go
Matthew 26 26 to 28 now as they were
eating Jesus Took bread and blessed and
broke it and gave it to the
disciples and gave it to displ said take
eat this is my body now watch Matthew 26
26-28 and he took a cup and when he had
given thanks he gave it to them saying
drink of it all of you for this is my
blood of the Covenant which is poured
out for many for the Forgiveness of sins
there is Zechariah 99 verses 9 to1 being
fulfilled Jesus is the king who entered
Jerusalem with salvation to those who
believe writing the F of an ass and it
is his blood of the Covenant that sets
prisoners free from the waterless pit so
the pit that's waterless must refer to
hell because there is no water in hell
it's
fire and this will be confirmed by one
of the teachings of Our Lord when he
talks about the rich man of Lazarus so
now let's go into
G or
G and Hades or Hades however you want to
pronounce it Hades or Hades I've heard
people pronounce it
Hades would be the Greek synonym for the
Hebrew shol shol that refers to the
Abode of the Dead when they physically
die their Spirit Soul leaves their body
the Bible doesn't teach Soul sleep and
if they're unbelievers after Christ
after Christ has ascended if they're an
unbeliever they go to Hades and it's a
place where they are
tormented and they feel
torment Hades is the place where the
souls of the Dead who are
unbelievers go to it's that interim
period awaiting the day of Resurrection
where their souls will come out of Hades
and their bodies will be raised and they
will be United to their bodies stand
before the judge and give a life
sentence meaning a Life review why they
deserve to where they go and that's
where gah comes in
gah is where you are sent in your body
to be
tormented so the difference is Hades is
where your soul goes and awaits the
Judgment Day where you'll be United to
your body
and in your body you'll be thrown in G G
is where the soul and the body together
are sent to hell to be destroyed Hades
now after the time of Christ Hades in
the New Testament after the time of
Christ let me repeat after Christ's
death Resurrection Ascension to Heaven
Hades now becomes the place where the
souls the spirits of the disembodied
dead when you die your soul leaves goes
to wait an intern period waiting in
torment for the day of Judgment at the
day of judgment their souls will be
summoned out of summoned out of Hades
the pit refers to both Hades and hell to
come the pit is now and the pit will be
then on the day of judgment your souls
will come out of
Hades your body will be resurrected your
soul inhabit your physical body and then
after the Judgment you'll be thrown in
your body body into
G let me tell you some people say well
all right if they're in Hades why will
they then be
resurrected and placed in their bodies
let me explain
imagine a criminal imagine he murdered
someone he's put in jail until the
assigned
date his court date where he stands
before the judge he's already in jail
right he's already in
jail and he's waiting sentencing but he
knows he's not going to get out once in
jail he knows he's going to go before
the
judge to receive the
sentencing and why he's receiving that
sentencing once he sprs the judge the
judge says well you did this and this is
what you're going to do that's exactly
what happens when we die if you're a
Believer you go to the Heavenly City
Heavenly Paradise where the temple of
God God's palace is you're going to be
living in that City where you're going
to see Gardens and trees and loved ones
so you know that when Jesus comes and
your body is raised and you will dwell
your bodies you're going to be with him
forever because you're already there
with him in Paradise Heavenly Paradise
Heavenly
City but you are meant to inhabit
bodies the Bible says you were not
created to be
bodess the reason why we die is because
of
sin had there been no sin we would not
experience physical death where our
bodies returned to the dust God did not
create you to be disembodied Souls sin
destroyed that so God at the last day
will raise the dead in their bodies cuz
you're created to be embodied Spirits so
as an embodied Spirit a soul inhabiting
a physical body you'll either dwell with
Christ forever or apart from Christ
forever you were created to live in
bodies sin cause physical death where
your spirit leaves your body James 2:26
just as the body without the spirit is
dead so to faith without works is dead
Genesis 3:1
17:19 you shall go to the dust from the
dust you came to the dust you'll return
Genesis
3:17-19 God did not design humans to be
disembodied or bodess Spirits you were
created as souls and Spirits living in
bodies so during this intern period
Believers their soul Spirits are with
the Lord in that Heavenly City because
the Bible says it's a Heavenly City so
imagine a city well in a city you have
different sections just like in a city
you may have
you have the Senate so imagine the
Heavenly City and you have this huge
Palace this huge Temple and that's the
Palace of the king where the king dwells
and the angels are there before his
throne the most holy place in an altar
and outside the palace is this huge City
where there is a garden and trees and
flowers and you
Fellowship that's what the Bible says
Hebrews 12:22 to 24 it tells you you
have come to Mount Zion right right
Heavenly Jerusalem and in Hebrews 11
we're told that's a Heavenly
City so this is why when some people say
well no they're not in heaven they're in
Paradise no they're in heaven because
part of Heaven includes Paradise so
imagine Heaven as a huge City and you
have the Senate you have the temple the
palace and God's throne in the most holy
place and outside of it are all the
citizens of the city and perfect love
Bliss Joy Fellowship no sin no no
disease no gossip no slander so when
people say no you go to paradise not to
Heaven Paradise is in heaven imagine
Heaven is a city so once you go to
heaven you know your fate is sealed so
then why will you be judged now let me
explain that why will you then be judged
if you're already in heaven because the
Lord will give you a Life review showing
you that at the end of the day it was
the perfect love mercy and grace of our
Lord Jesus that saved you because by
your mere good Deeds you would never be
able to satisfy God so God in his Mercy
is rewarding your Deeds that are not
worth being rewarded it's number one
that's number one number
two it's also for your R ranks because
the Bible says there will be great in
the kingdom and there'll be least in the
Kingdom so well
Purgatory is only for believers
purgation is the purification of
Believers and the after life purging
them so that they can then enter into
their Heavenly Bliss so Purgatory is
another grace of our
Lord for those who are in Christ but
have been imperfectly cleansed due to
temporal sins that they haven't
confessed and turned away from that too
is the grace of Jesus Christ because
without the grace of Jesus Christ then
Purgatory wouldn't be a reality your
reality would be hell now I'm trying to
speak accurately from a Catholic
perspective and I'm still learning I
don't know much but I'm trying to
understand let me give you an example of
fire
purifying someone of sin without harming
them Isaiah 6
5-7 and I said wo is me for I am a man
for I am lost for I a man of unclean
lips and I dwell in the midst of a
people of unclean lips for my eyes have
seen the king the Lord of hosts now did
you catch it this in principle
is what Purgatory is when you see God's
infinitude his infinite Majesty Holiness
Purity Glory you see how unworthy and
dirty you are in comparison and you feel
too guilty to be in his
presence okay so what does God do does
he say yeah you're right you're not
worthy in my pres to be in my no look
what he does then flew one of the sarim
to me having in his hand a burning C
which he had taken with the tongs of the
altar so there's that Heavenly altar
where sacrifice offered to God so he
takes one of those coals remember it's
burning it's hot and he touched my
mouth and said behold this has touched
your lips your guilt is taken away and
your sin forgiven no pain no harm no
hurt but that burning coal representing
God's purifying fire
purify purge them of sin but no pain no
harm so God's fire can consume you or
Purge you 1 Corinthians 11:15 so the
second reason why Believers are already
in heaven will stand in judgment is to
determine their
ranks where does the bible say that some
will be great some will be least
depending on our faithfulness to the
Lord some will have higher ranks some
will have lower ranks Matthew 5 5:
19 Matthew 5:
19 there it says there'll be great and
least in the Kingdom okay Matthew 20
20-28 1 Corinthians chapter 3 vers 11-
15 and 1 Corinthians chapter 4: 3-5 now
let me show you where it says you will
have a body like our Lords Philippians
3:10-11 if you are dead meaning
physically your body will be raised like
Jesus's body was raised Philippians
31-1 that I may know him know Jesus
intimately and the power of Resurrection
but notice there's a
connection you will not be raised if you
don't suffer Resurrection presupposes
death I must die in order for me to be
resurrected that's why Paul is saying
you Christians you ain't going to have
it easy you want the res res rection
then you're going to have to also accept
suffering and death for Christ because
Jesus suffered and died before he was
raised there is no Resurrection for us
if we don't follow his path of suffering
like him and dying like him then we'll
be raised like him so I have to then
share in his sufferings becoming like
him in his death that if possible I may
attain the resurrection from the dead
now watch The Promise Philippians 3:20
to 21 so whether you like it or not guys
sucks being us we're going to have to
suffer we either suffer because we love
Jesus and the world hates us or we
suffer because of sin and that's a shame
there are two reasons why you suffer
according to scripture Philippians 320
to 21 but our Commonwealth is in heaven
we don't belong to this Fallen World
this Fallen World will be destroyed
because the Earth will be transformed to
be the Abode of righteousness where
there'll be no more sin No More Death no
more mourning no more disease no more
Satan no more evil Revelation 21 : 1 to8
specifically Revelation 21 veres 1 to4
but our Commonwealth is in heaven and
from it we await a savior the Lord Jesus
Christ so we're waiting for him to come
down from heaven to the Earth and when
he does here's the promise who will
change our lowly body to be like his
glorious body
glorious truth what a glorious promise
and blessing this body will be fleshly
like Jesus but like Jesus this body of
Flesh will be
immortal Incorruptible deathless like
Jesus's physical body my human nature
will be glorious immortal like Jesus's
human nature and that's his promise and
how does he do it how is he able to do
that for all of us how is he able to do
that for all of us millions of Believers
transforming all of us that is power
that is infinite
by the power which enables him his power
that he possessed with the father and
the spirit because the father's power is
the son's power is the spirit's power
and that power enables our lord
Jesus even to subject all things to
himself but it's not a power he abuses
it's not a power he misuses it's not a
power he uses to harm you because if he
was a cruel God he could torture you and
there's not a damn thing you could do to
stop him because he's too powerful he's
all powerful